there's one thing you're probably not
training that can drastically improve
your jump height your running speed and
your general athleticism that one thing
is ankle stiffness now this might sound
like a bad thing like something you
wouldn't want but in fact ankle
stiffness is a very positive thing for
athletes and we're going to explain why
in this video but first i'm going to
demonstrate how important it is by
jumping over this bin and I'm going to
do it in such a way that I'm barely
bending my legs I slept on the floor
with my son last night and very achy and
this grass is squishy and slippery what
could possibly go wrong now watch
carefully friends because the devil is
very much in the details as I'm jumping
I'm not bending my leg at any point
rather I'm just taking off from running
this kind of goes against what we
intuitively assume about jumping so
what's going on here what am I talking
about well ankle stiffness basically
refers to the strength of your angle
tendon its ability to return energy to
the ground you're usually jumping from
one leg and you normally have very
minimal contact time with the ground